you live in the safe little world where
no one challenges you and you're scared
shitless to do anything else don't tell
me about my world don't tell me about my
world i mean you just want to have your
little fling with like the guy from the
other side of town then you're gonna go
off to stanford you're gonna marry some
rich prick who your parents will approve
of and just sit around with the other
trust fund babies and talk about how you
went slumming too once why are you
saying this
what is your obsession with this money
my father died when i was 13 and i
inherited this
you don't think every day i wake up
and i wish that i could give it back
that i would give it back in a second
if it meant i could have one more day
with him but i can't then that's my life
and i deal with it so don't put your
[ __ ] on me when you're the one that's
afraid i'm afraid what am i afraid of so
what the [ __ ] am i if you're afraid of
me you're afraid that i won't love you
back you know what i'm afraid too
[ __ ] it i want to give it a shot and at
least i'm honest with you i'm not honest
with you no what about your 12 brothers
all right
no you're not going you're not leaving
what do you want to know what that i
don't have 12 brothers
that i'm a [ __ ] orphan no you don't
want to hear that no you don't want to
hear that you don't want to hear that i
got [ __ ] cigarettes put out on me
when i was a little kid
that this isn't [ __ ] surgery that the
[ __ ] stabbed me you don't want
to hear that [ __ ] skylar don't do it
don't tell me you want to hear that i
want you to be here because i want to
help you because i don't know what the
[ __ ] what do i got a [ __ ] sign on my
back that says save me do i look like i
need that no god i just want to be with
you i love you you're bullshitting me
i love you
i wanna hear you you say that you don't
love me
because if you say that
then i won't call you
and i won't be in your life
i don't love you
[Music]
uh
[Music]